a handheld pocket AI companion the
rabbit R1 and it's iconic we're working
with all the best language models that's
how rabbit always works there's one
scenario I use the vision to look at a
Discord cuz rabbit now in the past three
days we have 5,000 members I'm the
customer service guy there I start
getting lost because the message is too
much I was on a zoom call with some
other guy I literally just point the
camera after four or five seconds it
gives me the report which you would
normally you might have a college
educated person who you say summarize
what's happening in the customer support
line exactly for me every day or you
might point an llm at it and have it do
a report